はい 何か質問ございますか
先生 そういういろいろ修行のことで論争が起こる場合っていうのは
仏教に何か 例えば現代的な知識
脳科学とか あとはいろいろな他の宗教の教えとを混ぜ込んで教えを作る場合と
あとは仏教なら仏教で
例えば経典の解釈が違うとか
こちらの経典を私は重視するとかっていうのでだいぶ違うんじゃないかなと
同じ意見が違えるとか
歯を立てるっていうのもだいぶ違ってくるんじゃないかなと思うんですけど
その辺はどのように区別するんですか？考えればいいんでしょうか
そこはね いろんな現代思考を取り入れる
脳科学を取り入れるところはもう簡単に捨てられますけどね
関係ないとは捨てられますが
いろいろ経典とって あれやこれやというと
これとても危険なことにはなります
で 一番心配なのはそれなんです
本当はお釈迦様 お釈迦様は現代の科学を知りませんからね
お釈迦様はキリストのという教えが現れるだろう
そんなの知ったわけじゃないし
でも一神教だけは知ってたんですけどね
あり得るんだと 一神教はそれだけのことで
だから取り入れても別に何のこともない
もうすぐ拭けばなくなるというね
ガラスにホコリたまったような感じで
そういうやっぱり だからお釈迦様はそれを注意してますよ
教えの中から分派が出ることはもう一番もうこれが危険であると
それでは仏道は壊れますよと
だからどう解決すればいいかと
ない もう壊れます 例えば
ある人がある経典をずっともう私はこれこそやと思って
私はこの経典であると
また別な経典取り出して
お互いいろいろ自分好きな修行法をやってくると
もう解決策ないんですよ
で そういう経典があるんだから違いますよと言えないし
だからもう必ず破壊になってしまうんです
経典たくさんあっても
仏道は一つしかないんですよ
これはだから何？作り方のマニュアルだから
それは一つしかないんです
だから機械の例えばある機械が買ってきたその機械の使い方
使用法 ユーザーマニュアルありますね
ユーザーマニュアルたくさんあるわけじゃないんです
例えばコンピューターの場合も大量の本があるでしょ？結局同じことなんで
どんな本をとってみたっても
同じこと繰り返して繰り返して
で 三分でウィスターを知り尽くす本とかね
ウィスターのバイブルとかね
ウィスターのバイブルという本はすごく分厚くて
もう結構迷惑なぐらい厚い
置く場所もないぐらいね
まあただ単に違うところは
きめ細かく一つずつ一つずつ中のことを説明している
九十分でわかる本の場合は
まあ基本的に使うウィンドウの開け方
閉め方 ファイルの保存方法
まあそんな程度で で もう何て言いますか
画面をね 自分好きなように変える方法とか
壁紙を変える方法とか
そんなところで終わったりするんです
バイブルの場合は マイドキュメントファイルはCディスクから別なディスクにどうやって引っ越しするのかとか
で よく使わないプロセッサーが送っているプログラムはもうこういうこういうもので
こういうこういう仕事しかしないんだから
好きな人はそこは削除してもよろしいと
削除する方法とか ちょこちょこと専門っぽい
そんな差なんですよ 結局はウィンドウの使い方決まってるんだからね
変わらないんです 電子レンジの使い方のユーザーマニュアルにはイラストあるかないか
どうでもいいんです 別に
漫画本にすると 今考えたら
何で日本で作るいろんな機械には厚いマニュアルが来る
何で漫画で来ないのかと
漫画で来た方がみんな読むと思いますしね
そうすると機械は正しく使うと思いますけどね
私は絶対に読みませんだけどね
漫画で来たら私の人も楽なんです
なぜかと言うと そのまま粗大ゴミじゃなくてリサイクルに出しますからね
あれ普通文字で書いているんだから
もし何かあったら読んだ方がいいということで置いておくんですね
これかえってまた溜まっちゃうんですよ
ゴミとして 漫画だったら読まないんだから
そのまま捨てられるんだから
私にとっても楽ですし
皆様にも楽なんです 皆様漫画なら読むでしょうしね
だから言いたいポイントは
電子レンジの使い方 漫画で描いても
どんな文章で描いても
英語で描いても 結局は使い方は同じなんです
だから経典たくさんありますよ
当然 で 経典ではいろんな論点は分析して広げて説明してはいきます
が 仏道になってくるといつでもワンパターンで同じなんです
決まって同じパターンで微妙に言葉も変えません
例えば なんていうか こういうのがありますね
沙門果経というね  論点は出家してどうなるのかと
無駄じゃないのかという質問なんですね
我々百姓さんたちはね
もう食い物をやられますから
結果があって百姓やってますよと
あなた方にそういう結果があるのかと言ったら
ありますよと 最初から小さなどうでもいい結果ところから始めて始めて
最後に最後に最後に最後に瞑想の世界に禅定の世界に入って悟りで終わっちゃうんです
そこは他の経典でもそのセクションだけは変わらない
カースト制度はバラモン人こそ世界で一番トップやと言ったら
あ そうですかと言って
人間の分析に入りまして
生き方やと ただ人間いろいろいるんだと
自分でも苦労し 自分で苦労する人と
あるいはもう自分でも苦労して人々を苦しみに導く人やとかね
自分でも苦労しないで他人にもも苦労しないように導きたいとか
種類あります いろいろありますよ
あって では自分でも苦労しない
他人にも幸福の道を導く人は誰でしょうかと
最後はそれは仏道だから
その時何のことなく そのヴィヴィッチェはカーミーヴィッチャク スレダンメヒ サヴィタッカンガヴィチャーランサマー
ジタン ドゥッチッジャハナウパサンパジッヘリとか
まあそれからずっと第一禅定から四禅定まで
場合によって無色界のことも言ったりとか
最終的には空住滅度を知って
この世を知っている時はもうカーマサワプチッタンキムッチャティ バヴァサワプチッタンキムッチャティ ヴィッジャサワプチッタンキムッチャティ
ヴィプッタンスミティ・ニャーナナ・ゴティとか
そのワンフレーズで全部終わっちゃうんです
もう煩悩がそこで欲の行も消えると
身も行も まあ存在 なんてまたバワーサは無明の行も消えて無明の心に達しますよと
そこは変わらないどこでも
ですから 経典を持って議論すると結構厳しいんですね
だからお釈迦様はそこはどうにもならんだから経典を持って議論するなよと禁止だとしているんです
で こちらでは具体的な経験でいえば
もうもう経典読んで アーナパーナ・スッタンタというね
経典があるんだけど それに乗っちゃうんですね
だって世間で誰でも呼吸やってますからね
だから乗るんだからその時点で間違いでしょうね
世間に乗っただけで で
呼吸瞑想にするんですね
呼吸瞑想ダメと私には言えませんよ
だって経典がありますから
私に言えるのは じゃあ呼吸瞑想ではもう悟りに出せと教えてますけど
だったら他の瞑想どうするのかと
他の瞑想でも達するんだよと教えているんではないんですかと
うん だからその問題解決するために瞑想方法ということで
四念処経を語られておいて
そちらでははっきりと道一つだけ
一つですと 二つないんだということで言っておいたんですね
だから結局はマニュアルとしてね
四念処経典置いておいたんですね
四念処経典の中ではどんな瞑想も入ってます
結局は 第一番目のセットに入っているのは
その他の瞑想 全部それに入れているんです
呼吸も入ってるんです
浮上感も入ってるんです
地水火風を観察することも入ってるんです
行住捨というね そういう行いで瞑想することも入ってるんです
全部入れてるんです それから次からないんです
感覚の住から三ステップは入ってない
だからそれは同じどこで
だから経典を持って議論はできるはずがないんです
もし別な修行法を誰が語るならば
どこかでもうツムリの世界に足を引っ張られていることは当然あります
その問題解決のためにお釈迦様は結構お釈迦様は工夫してますけど
例えばこの指を鳴らすぐらいの時間でも
慈しみのメッターの気持ちを抱くならば
その人はとても尊いんであると
もうすっかり入ってますから
それならその人はどんな幼いでも受ける権利持ってますよと
指を鳴らすぐらい時間でも慈しみの気持ちを
メッターをバハワナするならばと
やっぱりそれぐらいすごいなと
メッタバハワナ じゃあ私はメッタワナするそうと思ったって
次の経典でカルナ・バハワナ
鳴らすぐらい時間が同じこと
その問題解決してるので
ではカルナ ちょっと待ってください
ムディター・バハワナ
指鳴らしたら同じパターンで言うんです
あ じゃあムディター じゃあちょっと待って
ウペッカー・バハワナ
瞬間あっても もうどんな幼いものでも受ける資格があるんだよと
ではウペッカーの ちょっと待ってください
瞬間たりとも瞬間ぐらいでも人は現象は無常であると観察するならば
もう全てのどんな人の幼いでも受け止めよろし
それで無常の瞑想に行くんです
じゃあ一つこれやって選んでみなさいと
選べなくなっちゃうんですよ
[笑い]経典を編集するときでも
あえてそういうところを一箇所に並べて置いておくんです
だから読者通しで読むとつまらないんですけど
あれは専門的にすごい考えて一箇所に揃ってるんです
読書じゃないんです 経典は
そういうわけで いろんな経典
自分好みの経典を選ぶことは構いませんが
だからといって仏道はたくさんあるっていうことは成り立たないんです
解脱という心の変換というのは
起こす方法っていうのはたくさんあり得るわけじゃないんです
つもり世界だったら いくらでもあり得るんです
お釈迦様はもう医者に例えて語るのはそういうわけで
病気だったら病気になった原因というものがあるんですよ
それをなくす方法っていうのは一つしかないんですよ
薬なら何でもいいんだよということではないんですね
この病気にはこの薬だと
はい 世間ではね いろんな仏教の同じテーラワーダの仲間でもね
いろいろ瞑想法を言ったりすることは
結構困ったもんだっていうことだけで
どうにもならないんですよ
本当は だからとても危険なことをやってるんです
みんな 出しゃばって自分の方法はもう謳うんじゃないんです
私はすごい気持ち悪くするんです
いくら立派なお坊さんであってもね
わざと自分に言ってることは強調するなと見えちゃうとね
もう相手にあんまり私はしません
私も同じ専門家だからね
一般の方々はそうじゃないんだから
もう好みで言っちゃいますからね
そこで 一般テーラワーダ世界でたくさん瞑想法があるということで
どちらでもいいんじゃないかということではないんです
よくあることっていうのは
このアクセスだけですよ
入門はサマーディで入門しなくちゃいけないんだから
それはいくらでも方法ありますから
呼吸からでもよろしいし
どんなことでもよろしいし
だからみんなこの初心者に瞑想を指導する場合は
何か方法を取って 人気ある方法を取って選んだりして
それは別にどうってことないんで
ヴィパッサナーになってくると同じ道に
同じ道になるように一切テキストに書かれてます
サマーディ瞑想しようが
不浄の観察しようが 死随観やろうが勝手にしなさいよと
それは全て入門瞑想で
そこで瞑想の世界に 心清らな世界にアクセスするんです
新幹線乗りたければ もう方法はどうでもいいんですよ
品川か東京駅に行かなくちゃいけないんです
それからあれやこれやと
私はこの乗り物好き 私はこの乗り物好きとは成り立ちません
品川までタクシーに乗ったって
もう勝手にしろよと あるいはかなり回り道で地下鉄に乗って
またあちらで乗り換えて
こちらで乗り換えて もうもう行けますけどね
地下鉄に繋げてでも なんとか結構回り道になりますけど
品川までは行けますよ
それはどうでもいいんです
それからは新幹線一本になります
そういうことで あの 悟りを教える気持ちはない場合は
まあその自分が習っている瞑想で満足して終わっちゃうんですね
私は内観やってますよとかね
私はなんだらかんだらよとか
まあいろいろ そういうことにして自慢するということは
まあ悟りはもうには達しませんということに決めつけているんですね
気分良ければよろしいと
いうことですから 仏道でなくなっちゃうんですね
結局は はい まあそれ以外はそうしようことはないんですから
何か質問なければ はい
禅のエネルギーが人間にとっては結構ストレスになるっていう
あ すみません 禅のエネルギーが人間にとって
それが溜まることが非常にストレスになるというお話だったんですけれども
例えばあの すごく最近は結構自分を少しいいことして修行してるような気分になっているので
ちょっと怠けてもいいんじゃないかと思ったり
あるいは あのなんか綺麗に
割と心が綺麗で 今そういうつもりになっていて
時に何か物足りなくなって悪いことをしてしまうような
そういう例で自分は理解したんですけれども
その禅のエネルギーがストレスになるというところをもう少し詳しく教えていただけないでしょうか
教えてあげたいんだけど
時間かかっちゃうんです
で あの朝会チャーナ 5番目の講義をね
なんとか見てください
結構時間かかるんです
今言ったことは禅のストレスじゃないんです
本当は で 怠けてみたくなったりするということは
あの やっぱり 正しいやり方じゃないんです
結局は 悪ストレスは止めるんで
悪ストレス止めること自体はストレスですけど
ストレスだからそれ止めるっていうことは話にならないんです
で 明確な説明する 明確ではなくて理解しやすくしますけど
例えばある人が嘘をつかないという戒律を決める
いいことでしょうに だからいいこと積みっていうことにならないんです
嘘つかないこと自体が
その人にとっては結構ストレスになるんですよ
楽じゃないんです 嘘つく人生もストレスであって
しかし ひどい目に遭ったりするんです
悪影響ばっかしで やがてすべてなくなってしまいますね
人生まで終えなくちゃいけないはめにもなります
じゃあそのストレスをやめて嘘をつかないということにしたら
それからも大変なんです
世界で生きて 嘘をつく世界で生きていかなくちゃいけないんだから
嘘つくみんなが嘘をつく間で一人だけ嘘をつかないということは相当大変です
しかし それは禅のストレスなんです
ストレスが溜まって まあ少々 1週間も嘘をつくないで頑張ったんだからね
まあ 1日ぐらいは嘘をついてやるぞと思っちゃうと
はい それは話になりません
それで全ストレスが全部解放しちゃって
なくなっちゃって また新たに悪ストレス溜まっただけで
だから禅のストレスとは嘘つかないというこの大変さを覚悟しなくちゃいけないんですよ
これって結構大変だと
楽じゃないんだと それでもやるんだよと
だからそこもまた法則で
嫌なのは嫌やという人っていうのはもうとんでもないんですよ
何かやるためには嫌なものを乗り越えなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからどうせ道が険しいっていう覚悟は最初から必要なんで
山登りする場合は 山は危険でもう命取りになるんだよと
険しい所やと その覚悟もなしに登山してみようと思っちゃうと何もならんでしょうに
あ 疲れた やめたっていうことで終わっちゃいますからね
ちょっと寒いんだね ちょっと上がったところで寒くて
まあいいや もう降りましょうと
それって人生ですかね
だから寒いのは覚悟 雪があるのは覚悟
登れないことの覚悟 滑ったら命がなくなるってことも覚悟で
登山家は頂上まで行くんですよ
それで頂上に登ったら
全てのストレスがそこで解放されて
すごいリラックスできる状態になるんです
そこまではストレスです
だから禅のストレスっていうのは
やっぱり悪をやめて善に決めることも結構踏ん張らないとうまくは淡々
淡々は進まないんです
そういうことで 仏教ではストレスという単語はないんだから
現代用語だからね 現代用語の使い方を間違っていてね
悪いことにストレスと言ったりするし
これは善悪の問題じゃなくて
エネルギーが溜まるということでね
俗世間で生きている場合はゴミのように溜まるんだから
もうめちゃくちゃなんですね
禅の場合はもう逆にもう宝物溜まる
それでも重いことは重いんですよ
自分が何か大きな袋 袋を持っているんだと
俗世間で生きると袋で溜まるのは全てゴミなんですね
臭いんだから持ってきた
持ちたくはないということになるんですね
溜まれば溜まるほど不幸なことになるんです
禅の道を歩むと この袋に宝物が溜まるんですよ
それは捨ててはならん
重いんだからといって
重いことは確かに重いんです
しかし 全部溜まってるのは宝物なんですね
だから重いんだとかね
苦しいんだとか 余計なことを言うんじゃないと
我慢しろよと 目的に達したら
それでも結構すごいことになるんだよと
だから長い道を歩んで
ゴミばっかり溜まって
最終目的地に行って袋を開けてみたら
何も役に立たない臭いゴミだけだからね
その人は鈍足不幸になるんです
禅の道を歩んだ人は目的に達して袋開けてみたらもう宝物ばっかしで
もう万々歳で問題はないんです
だからエネルギーの言葉で言えば
どちらでもストレスという言葉は使えるんです
そういうわけで 仏教はこのはっきりと力
力という言葉を使っています
力ってありますからね
力は善のエネルギーなんですね
だから良いストレスなんです
講演では力は説明しなかったんですけど
まあ紹介だけですからね
力は禅のエネルギーなんですね
だから良いことをして修行して
ストレス溜まったらもうじゃあやめたではダメということだけですね
もう何をしたっても疲れますよと
俗世間でどっしりともう欲に溺れて生活したっても
クタクタ疲れてもう自己破壊になる
この世界でも疲れるんですけど
自己破壊には絶対ならないんですね
成長するんですね ということで
あの もう疲れてやめたくなったという気分は当然出てくるんです
良い道は目的に達するまで苦労の覚悟で
ストレスの覚悟でやらなくちゃいけないんです
禅のストレスと悪のストレスの違うところは
まあ禅のストレスでは身体には悪影響は全くない
で 心にも悪影響は全くない
心が成長したストレスなんです
壊れたいストレスじゃないんです
例えば物を破壊する時も疲れるんですね
ものを作る時でも疲れるんでしょ
疲れは同じですけど ぐちゃぐちゃ破壊して疲れたと言っても何の意味もないんですね
何かよく素晴らしいものを作って
くったくた苦労して素晴らしいものを作ってしまったと
くったくた疲れたことは確かですけど
強いものはできているんですね
それは禅の法のストレスはそういうもので
だから身体には問題ないし
心には問題起きませんし
幸福になります で 別な言葉で言えば悪いストレスで頑張る人
欲で頑張る人々は悪 いやもう後悔するばかりで
あれはダメでした これはダメでした
これは失敗でしたとかね
なんでこうなるんでしょうかとかね
というマイナスのことしか出てこないんですね
禅のストレスはもう頑張ってよかった
よかった 頑張ってよかった
苦労してよかったとかね
その時我慢してよかったとかね
その時に耐えて忍耐したことがすごく良かったとか
良かった 良かったという結果が出ているんですね
悪のストレスの場合 悪かった
悪かった 悪かった 悪かったということになるんですね
差は随分違います ストレスという言葉で使えば
まあストレスです はい
まあ他質問ございますか
声高き死の黄金っていう言葉が出てきたんですけど
死の王国っていうのはどういうことなんですか？ 輪廻のことでしょう
他質問ございませんか？ 勤めている幼稚園で 12月8日
浄土会を行ったんですが
スジヤータさんがお布施したという父親の話と
スジヤータさんというのはどういう方だったのかを知りたかったんですけど
お布施は一回だけだったんでしょうか
それはあんまり記録ないんですね
スジャータさん 私もまあちょっとしたエピソードではないかなという気分でね
学先取りで思っていたんですけど
実際インドに行ってみたら
まあちゃんともう考古学的な史跡はいっぱいあるんですね
スジャータさんのお城というのがすごい家があって
そこはお寺になってしまって
仏頭もあってね まあやっぱりそういう発掘して発掘していくとね
まあありましたから やっぱり経典の通りにかなり豊かな地方のすごい偉い富豪な方でしたでしょうとは思うし
おそらくどうでしょうかね
スジャータさんがこの子供を授かることで神に願い立てていたんだからね
なんか微妙にその子供やがて出家したような話もなんかうろ覚えがありますけどね
あんまり記録ないんですね
明確な記録は だからそちらで仏教をハイライトする仏教エピソードでハイライトするのは
この お釈迦様に菩薩の時
最後に挙げたお布施 それを召し上がってからブッダになるんですね
それは一回だけしかできませんだからね
自分のご飯を召し上がって悟りに達すると
で それは一回しかできませんし
お釈迦様の最後の布施も一回しかできませんし
チョンダさんが最後の布施だから
チョンダさんが一生一回しか布施してないと言えないでしょうに
常識的にはね チョンダさんが初めから仏教徒でお釈迦様のことは大好きで
もういっぱい布施していたでしょうに
だからお釈迦様は最後の旅でチョンダの村に行ったら
チョンダさんが腕を振るって料理を作って差し上げただけ
当然その前もいろんな時お布施したでしょうに
だからたくさんのお布施したことがあったんだからこそ
お釈迦様はすごく円いお腹で
もうやっと歩いてきたんだと
それよく知ったんでしょうしね
もうそろそろ二度と来られないでしょうと
こんな体ではと だから本人がよく知っている
これはおそらく もう自分にとってはもう二度と布施できないでしょうと思って
一生懸命もう腕を振るった頃じゃなくて
ものすごい心を込めて一生懸命お布施をしたんで
そのお布施も最後でした
だからスジャータさんも最初のお布施する時は仏教はなかったし
それから自分が布施した方がブッダになったあれこれするでしょうに
だからそれから それこそだってスジャータさんの
家はお寺にしているんだから
その家からみんな仏教徒になったことは当然でしょう
だから何だら何でもかんでも記録するのはいちめんどくさいんだからね
もう他の宗教と違って
こっちはもうあまりにもエピソードありすぎだからね
それまで作り話でほとんどないんだから
だから大事なところだけ覚えて記録するんです
年代的なところは仏教
インド歴史ではね すごい曖昧曖昧だからね
繋がりにくいんですね
おそらくこのヤサというアラカンがスジャータの息子ではなかっただろうかと
そうすると年代的に合わなくなっちゃうんですね
ヤサはいくらかと若者で
だから まあスジャータさんの息子は赤ちゃんであったということは言えませんから
子供を授けたら神様にお供えをそういうことをやってやろうと思って
で 子供が生まれて結構時間経ってからやった可能性あるし
あるいは子供が生まれたから
毎年毎年何か毎年やっていたような気がしますね
毎年お供えをする だから
もしかすると息子が若者でいたかもしれません
それで その年だけ限って
やけに物事はうまくいくと
とてもこのミルクを入れて炊くご飯っていうのはとっても美しく出来上がったりして
この泡立ちもかなり不思議だと
泡が立てて弾けるんだけど
全部中で弾けるんだそうです
一つも外へ出ていかないです
これすごく不思議に見てる
だからいくら豪奢な富豪の人であっても
そういうことは自分の手でするんだからね
召使いには頼まないんだから
で 丁寧にまあ上に天井も作って
もう汚れないように 今も紙にいろんな食べ物を作る場合はね
口にも何かつけて もうかなり苦労しますけどね
やってるとこの泡立ちも面白いし
泡が上がってきて 中で弾けていく
中で弾けていくと 外に漏れない
鍋は美しいままで で それで自分の召使いの女小児のこの気のところをね
綺麗にしてくださいと
これからお供え持ってくるんだから
そしたらこの女の人が大変だと
神様が降りて待ってるんだと
で勘違いするんですね
お釈迦様は身体的にはね
何か不思議な方でしたからね
みんなあの人誰ですかとね
もうすぐすごい印象的にはね
だから普通の どうせ釈迦族でしょうし
王子でしょうし で ブッダになる体ですからね
ブッダになる心で生まれたんだから
身体には微塵も異常があるはずがないんです
身体は心が作るんだからね
それから覚悟をしているんですね
人はもう命捨てる覚悟っていうのは一番輝いてる時ですよ
もう人間に見えません
もう命捨てる覚悟でいるんです
だから召使いは大変なことになってる
神様が降りてきて待ってるんだよと
スジャータさんはそんなにそれに驚いたことはないんですけど
で 金の鉢にね ご飯入れて持って行って
私の希望を叶ったんだから
これをお供えしていますと
ですから あなたの希望もこれで叶いますようにというふうにスジャータさんが祝福して帰るんです
そういうエピソードですからね
まあよくわからないんですけど
とにかく論理的に言えば
それからいろいろ伏せたっていうことはね
だからなんとなくスジャータさんの息子がヤサという人ではなかったという話もありますね
調べてないんだから あまり明確なことはちょっと言えません
それだったら 仏教は突然抜群にもう花が開くようにカーッと開けたのはヤサさんの若者が入ったんだからなんですね
突然六十人にもなっちゃったんだからね
みんなまとめて その六十人の中で五人比丘引いたら五十五人も若者なんです
それでお釈迦様がもうみんな悟りに達したんだだから
じゃあ伝道ということに決めたんです
それだったら仏教においてはね
もうすごい残る 形跡を残したことになりますね
そういうことで  それでは回向の文で
回向の文  仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
彼の者に慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって 全ての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして癒されますように
サッベテ jo vi vajjantuサッバローゴーナッサトゥマテーバワットワンタラーヨー スキーディーガーユコーバワバウォトゥサッバマンガランラッカンド
ゥサンバデヴァータサンバブッダヌバヴェーナサダーソッティバワントゥテーバウォトゥサッバマンガランラッカンドゥサンバデヴァータサンバダンマヌバヴェーナサダ
ーソッティバワントゥテーバウォトゥサッバマンガランラッカンドゥサンバデヴァータサンバサンガーヌバヴェーナサダーソッティバワントゥテーアビワダナシーリッサ
ニッチャンワッダパチャヤーノチャッターロダンマワッダンティヤーユワンノスカンバラマーユラーローギャサンパッティサンガサンパッティメーヴァチャアトーニッバーナサンパッティミナーテーサミッジャトゥ
では どうもありがとうございます